[Music]
gentlemen again congratulations on the
film it is so incredible and
congratulations on the sag nominations
and really
you guys are getting so much praise for
it but i have to ask you about
how did you guys kind of reconcile the
fact that such an american film was
nominated for best foreign language at
the golden globes i mean
i'm sure you appreciative be honored but
it seems so strange for such an
american story yeah you know it
it's it's weird because in the back of
my mind like
um when i think about language when i
talk to my mom and dad we don't
always connect using korean or english
we we just
have gestures and facial expressions
because we have this natural language
barrier um so i've always felt like
there's there should be no distinction
of language but that we're all really
speaking human
to each other you know even if we're not
speaking english to each other so
um when this happened and there's this
delineation with language
um it it feels like uh like an external
sort of category for me which
i don't always understand um and
more i just feel more sympathy to the
people who really feel a lot of uh
offense to it and feel like you know
once again we're being treated as
foreigners and
all this stuff that i totally understand
but in my view
the characters in this film speak human
and that's what they're doing to each
other with their faces
you see it in yeti you see it in steven
and alan
and um that that's what i hope for this
film that everybody will
watch it and not think about language
they don't even know if they're reading
subtitles because
they get lost in the humanity of it
well i mean if they're watching the film
i don't see how they can't and i think
that's spared out i mean this film still
certified fresh
critics audiences i'm so glad that more
folks are going to get a chance
to see it but alan i'm going to have to
ask you
as people start seeing it you know
you're going to get to go to the sags
now are you excited to maybe you know
do your like zoom party are you getting
your suits ready for award season
yes what did you think when you got
nominated can you give me a reaction
i'm like yay
i love that and i also love that this is
a film like you said as folks get a
chance to see it it
sort of continues i think a great trend
that you know uh director bong talked
about when he was doing the awards tour
for parasite is folks being able to sort
of like
hurdle the one-inch barrier subtitles to
open up an entire world
of cinema and stephen i just want to
talk to you
as far as like the korean influence here
i mean what you've worked with some of
these filmmakers what do you which films
or filmmakers are you hoping folks will
discover
thanks to what you guys have done here
and and films like parasite
oh man um you know i just hope i i don't
know i think there's so many wonderful
talents
um kind of everywhere um i see so many
new uh chinese films being really
beautiful um korean films there's um
i i think house of hummingbird is a
really wonderful film
the world between us is a really
wonderful film too
yeah i mean i hope it just opens up a
dialogue of understanding that like
these like director bong said that these
these uh
subtitles are just literally tiny tiny
barriers
of examining the humanity that all of us
share
and so hopefully we're headed there yeah
i really love it and i love the fact
that you know we're able to cover these
films and really get to talk about it
because yeah it just opens up a whole
different world of cinema and it seems
like it'll
never be ending because there's always
different type of stories to be told
um but isaac i have to talk to you about
this one
because this is an immigrant story and
one thing i remarked on it is it's one
with very little racism throughout it
which i think was an incredible choice
because so often
immigrant tales are very much rooted in
that and i thought that was such an
interesting choice to tell this story
and i wondered
um at what point did you make that
decision or is that just how it played
out
um it i made that decision early on
um i'm glad that you you like that
choice uh
because for me i that was kind of a
gamble like i i knew that people would
be expecting a lot of racism uh to be
honest i thought
with a story like this you often see
that um
but first of all that wasn't my
experience growing up like
i i did encounter racism but most of the
time
my existence was not defined by that
racism and it wasn't defined by that
in my own family most of the time i'm
just trying to relate to my family to be
honest
um and then my interactions with the
community uh there's so many that just
ended with love maybe it started with
friction but it really ends with uh
people seeing each other for who they
are um so
i wanted the film to function in that
way i didn't want it to
um just knee-jerk say well these are
white southerners so they're going to be
racist like i think that in itself is
is problematic um so yeah i i hope uh
i hope that resonates somehow i thought
it was really incredible and again it
really allows you to just focus
in on the family and the dynamic and
one of the great dynamics of course is
stephen and alan and the way you guys
had to do that together so
i want to go back to the whole audition
process allen because i do know
that you very much stood out so do you
remember that day when you were working
with stephen
and and you knew you were trying to
audition for it at all
yeah i remember some of it
we went into plan b into a room
i went into a room below and met stephen
the
and julia came the
best yeah yeah casting director
and steven taught me like
uh something called
doctor oh that's right
oh good one all right stephen what's
this real quick so i want to hear all
about it
oh it's like korean pogs oh nice
oh that's dope
so do you like like bang them against
each other yeah you try to flip the
other persons and you get to take it
um but that's so keen that you remember
that
i actually forgot about that so you have
a better memory than i do
was i scary though ellen like when i
came back into the room is your dad
me not really dang alan's never scared
never never seen him scared i mean and i
agree that alan said um was isaac was
like hey you know that
like after we did the improv she's like
you know that were this was pretend
right we were
we're not we're done now and then i was
just like yeah
yeah i know i'm just like
no in real life i'm like that was fake
was that when you knew isaac that he was
the kid when he was just like yeah i got
it was that the moment we were like all
right we're good
i mean he convinced me he fooled me i
thought i thought you know he was really
scared
or something but then it turns out you
know he's just in the scene he's acting
so uh when you see that you know that
you're going to be all right on set
where it is
first of all congratulations on the
nominations um it's been incredible
especially the sag nominations i'm just
curious what are you i'll start with you
yuri what are you thinking about the
awards season are you getting excited to
you know
come in and uh sort of i guess meet the
glitterati of hollywood
foreign
enjoy it it is it's really incredible
and
i think even more people are going to
start to uh
appreciate it but let's backtrack just a
little bit um
young i'll start with you this is one of
the first big things i think a lot of
americans have seen you in
i you know spotted you and since eight
but for other folks this may be their
first introduction
so i'm just curious um what made you
sign on to do this one
because of the friends
you know when you get old you can just
focus just
one thing not when you are young well
you can just uh okay this script
script will be good for me good for my
future or something like that
but now after six years old i'm just
focusing
only people the one i love
the one i um appreciate or
the one who is very precious to me
that my precious friend introduced the
script
and then of course the script wasn't
good maybe i would say no but
while i was reading it and then
it i felt very genuine and authentic so
i said
middle of the reading i called her is it
real story of him and she said yes so i
said okay i will do it
let's start i love that i love that so
much because it came from a place from
the heart and you can tell that
when you see the performances because
they're so touching and they're so
moving you can tell that everybody
became a family on set and and yuri
monica especially i find her your
performance of her to be such a delicate
thing because
she keeps her emotions um too close to
her chest at the beginning
and she slowly unravels them so i
wondered if you could talk about
how you played that to give it a slow uh
reveal of
how she felt
[Music]
that's so beautiful and yeah that's
that's exactly it because when you hit
that climax you
especially feel it i mean it really hits
home the whole emotion of the film
um before i get out of here um yujung i
wanted to talk about alan
because i just got done interviewing him
and from the first time i met
him at like sundance to now he is just
effervescent and just like this ball
of kid energy which is infectious but
like a little hurricane it's hard to
contain
so talk about containing the hurricane
to give that beautiful performance that
you guys were able to do because it's
i'm sure there's a lot of work on your
side to make that happen as well
sorry disappoint you i didn't work a lot
because it's all isaac's job
because yeah the director knows how to
control him first i was scared to just
meet him because i heard that
he has not having experienced the acting
so i said
oh my goodness what i'm going to do with
this boy and then
oh no no no no he didn't you know he
really made me disappointed that he
memorized all the lines and then isaac
asked him to do
with me just you know get over the line
together
and then he was perfect memorizing
all the lines and then after that
uh either ask him to do
this okay you need some kind of shot i
think
from him just to smile look at me and
smile
and this kind of smile with that smile
and then look at the
camera and then give you a frown face or
something like that it's
all editing's job it's also
stupid
[Music]
but it is
i checked this this morning i didn't
know until today you're on a five
certified fresh hot streak your last
five films going back yeah have all been
certified fresh which is
quite a remarkable feat and this is all
you know post walking dead and i think
there must have been a lot of offers
after that and you could have gone a lot
of different directions but i think
looking at the films you did everything
from ocha and mayhem and sorry to bother
you and now minari
burning that's a those are specific
choices so
talk about how you made the choice to do
those films or
how you wanted to work with those
filmmakers um
you know it's strange because
you're asking me now from a kind of a
retrospective lens
and you know maybe i by this point kind
of compiled like a story
to tell about what happened and how i
made these choices
but in those moments like i don't feel
i don't know if i had agency like that i
i probably did i certainly said
no to things that i felt like
were just other versions of things that
i've tried before
um but i think i think i think
a lot of it is you know for me i'm just
i was really trying to find myself
i was really trying to find out who i
was and um
kind of get to play in roles that
allowed me the space
to express the fullness of of not
me per se but of a character you know
as as an asian american actor prior to
walking dead
if i had any opportunities opportunities
at all
it was really mostly to service larger
narratives
or kind of be like a
you know like a plot point by which to
weave the main character around and so
um i wanted to be the main character
that gets to have the plot points to
weave around
and you know even with mayhem i'm so
thankful to them for giving
my first chance at like a leading role
um
it wasn't a big budget and we shouted in
serbia
but we had some really wonderful people
with us you know uh
samara's incredible uh joe was great and
and and just to kind of do that and flex
that muscle
was attractive to me and then ultra i
think was
you know who wouldn't work for director
bomb you know i'm a huge fan
and so um you know him reaching out
and giving that part to me was
extraordinary
and painful because kaye was
you know very much something that i was
at the time of just somebody straddling
two worlds and being unable to service
either one
and um i think going through that
experience i wasn't necessarily super
conscious of what i was participating
in i would but like i realized halfway
through i was like oh man like
this is kind of how i feel and um it is
a painful realization
and then sorry to bother you was really
wonderful of just kind of speaking from
an asian american's perspective
even though it wasn't explicitly but
just in a different way of
mr steele your girl in that movie that's
what i love like
cheese was the guy that was coming to
slide into the dms to check on it i
thought that was so brilliant
you know that that's boots you know and
and
i guess on a larger note what what i
feel like is happening
when you think about you know ichang
gong and then you think of
and isaac um i'm just really attracted
to people that
are singular people you know
there's no other boots riley's there are
no other ichang dongs or bong journals
or isaac
chungs it's really just these people
that i gravitate towards that um
we can share an experience in a story
that they've crafted that feels so
unique
i remember reading started to bother you
and like
certain people reading and being like
what is this and then me reading it be
like
i gotta do this like i have to who
can write like this who has a mind like
this
and um and that that when i see that i'm
i'm i'm in
um so that's kind of where i'm at with
that
i love that you put it like that because
you're right and i'm sure you're just
going from job to job trying to do
interesting work but
when you can look back on it it really
is incredible and that was so cool and i
was like
getting ready for this to kind of chat
about that one too because
it the new york times profile i read um
where you kind of talked about this and
the identity and the choices that you
made i found it to be just so
fascinating
and interesting because the character
that you play in menari
is just like not about multifaceted at
all he is just like
a man on a mission one focus
one goal not listening to really any of
the noise on the outside and i think
that's
way more difficult i think than trying
to play a multi-faceted character in
some ways
to add that humanity so talk about that
balancing act
yeah jacob was jacob was an interesting
thing
person to to kind of climb into the mind
of
not because i didn't understand them at
all but because i think
you're you're kind of exploring the pain
of being alone
um the pain of isolation um in him
at least for me and i think that's where
i found a lot of his humanity
that uh he means well and he wants
things
and he loves his family and he
desperately wants to provide for them
but he doesn't know how to separate his
role and his duty and his function
from the love that he can also show his
family
and oftentimes that function and duty
takes
the role of love that he shows for his
family and his family doesn't know how
to
deal with that or accept that because
maybe it's not really the best way to
convey love
to just play your part and in that way i
think
you know jacob from the outside looking
in might
look and feel like a patriarch that's
dragging his family
through his own ego and ultimately it is
to some degree but from his perspective
he's also
just trying his best to provide for his
family and
he's doing it in the only way he's ever
known how and that's to give his
body and mind up to that struggle and so
um i think in some ways he feels deeply
alone and isolated from his own family
because they can't see
what he's providing for them or that's
what he feels like they can't see
um so yeah that was a that was kind of
the journey of
of jacob and it's interesting too
obviously because this is semi
autobiographical and i think even isaac
would be able to say that
some of the stuff that he experienced
was stranger than the fiction that he
put on screen but
in the end you're playing his dad and
and that's another delicate dance
too so i was just wondering if you guys
had any conversations with that i'm sure
he had to give you
a bit of freedom with it a little bit
but also he wanted to make sure that it
was true to the man that he was trying
to be
well you know to be quite honest um he
actually left a lot of space
he left a lot of space um he had no
specifics on how his dad needed to be
and in fact he never brought that
up as something that he needed to be
checked off
um he you know he he wrote something so
true in my opinion that was so
human that i think it created space
for a lot of people to have come in and
taken that role and imbued it with the
things that they knew
it just happened to be that you know
isaac and i share
a lot of our experiences together of an
immigrant life
of isolation and of also
understanding you know what it means to
be a father and so
yeah i think that i i think that really
speaks to on a larger note the
graciousness of someone like isaac you
know
as i get to know him more and um
as i get to see how he thinks and
how he's constructed this film and
written this film
i peel back all those layers and i
realize what's at the beating heart of
it all is just someone that like
deeply deeply cares about others
and uh about humanity in that way and
he cares not only about the characters
that he's created
but also he cares deeply about even the
audience
about um making sure that there is no
barrier
to accessing these people in this story
and
it's really about connection i guess
you'd have to be yeah because you
wouldn't want to be stifled in that it's
really incredible too because it feels
so lived and it's even more incredible
to realize that it was just a creation
that you guys were able to do from
taking it to the
from the page to the screen um i guess i
have to
definitely ask you about this one in the
fact that um
folks are now going to finally get to
see it and the scene
i guess it were that you end up with
yuri towards the end is
probably one of the most climactic
things but without spoiling it yet just
talk about her as a scene partner and
how you guys were able to work that out
because
in a lot of ways the movie lives or dies
by that scene
oh thanks yeah i'm so glad you enjoyed
that
you know um i can't say enough good
things about yeti
um she's incredible she
her role in this is so
so it's it's so meta too you know um
that particular scene um
i guess i gotta start from how we shot
the whole thing
you know we never really over talked
much um we maybe talked about that
particular scene
a lot in terms of um shaping
what i wanted to say in that moment and
maybe what
she wanted to say in that moment and we
got to some place that felt right for
the two of us
um but beyond that you know there was
many times where her and i really just
had single takes
um we kind of really lived an experience
and
the ways in which she was honest about
her approach to monica
and the ways that i would talk about my
approach to jacob
and kind of the the truthfulness that we
shared between each other
um and even in the disagreements of how
we saw
situations were part of it you know it
was part of making the tension of those
characters and so
um yeah i mean i
knew i could just trust her
intrinsically to be honest and truthful
all the time and you know if you have a
scene partner like that like that's
you're chilling i mean it didn't look
like y'all were chilling it looked
pretty powerful but i get what you're
saying as far as the work on the other
side
um last one and this one's a little bit
light but i just got to put it out there
uh your character jacob is like the
michael jordan of chicken and sexting
we we are very curious if you got good
at this and trust me when i say this was
a very big editorial conversation at
rotten tomatoes so please take this
seriously we want to know did you get
good
at telling the difference between male
and female i did i got pretty decent
you know actually who probably got
better is yeti
yeti yeti's the real i'm i'm probably
like
i'm probably like the scottie pippen no
maybe
maybe maybe i'll get all the credit
because
some dumb dumb weirdness but um she's
the real mvp
you know this body's a real mvp she's
she really
she really knew how to do that i think
for us it was
the practice of of practicing that with
our animal
wrangler and also you know my wife her
parents also
chicken sexed just like isaac's parents
um and they
taught us tips and tricks and we all
grew out our thumbnails
so that we could like open their vents
uh it was
it was a it was a fascinating time oh my
gosh
i really did not expect that to be such
a thing so i will have to i literally
was like he's not gonna say anything
about this chicken sex
stuff y'all are morbid but you know what
i'm i'm down with that one now
um and then just like a very last
question again just to follow up on the
parasite
now you guys entering in this
conversation logical best picture
nominee folks in my
seat who do this for a living are
already talking about that thing
man what do you think is going to be
like this next section when we get back
into theaters do you think it's just
going to push even further and
if so what are you excited to see next
what kind of stuff would you like to see
american audiences come sort of import
over
i don't know i mean i think we're also i
think for america what's fascinating
about
especially this film is kind of really
digging into
what's already been here you know and i
think that's kind of touching on
what we're facing with minari in terms
of i think
this conversation around foreign
language and and
and even parasite you know parasite um
opened many doors and broke down a lot
of barriers on a larger i think
humanity level of just understanding
each other between cultures
um but their humanity that they're
expressing
is unencumbered by the american gays
because
they're korean people and they're making
it from korea so they're not considering
us whereas our film
does have to navigate the constant
consideration
of who we are in the midst
of a primarily white majority american
audience and so um a lot of the time the
ways that that would express
is we end up explaining ourselves or we
end up
um telling the audience how
we are oppressed by the majority
or how the majority factors into our
story but the truth is is we weren't
even considering
them because that's our story our story
doesn't bring home
a consideration of the majority american
whiteness
at a constant level it's just like i'm
me and i am i exist and this is from my
point of view
and i think it was really cool to be at
a time where
an american company in plan b
and a24 can finance and produce
and make a a language a
non-english language american film
i mean what a new foundation what a new
frontier
and um i hope that
you know if anything comes about it's
that we get to really understand what
makes america
um more all the things that have always
been here which is the
just all of us there's so many different
things that make america
and um i'm interested in that as a next
step for
us on the american side and then beyond
that the world is just getting more and
more global anyhow and so
you know hopefully we get to be human
together
at some point
you